we seem to have a ton of juice and verb
and like Joy
when benyama with the midi knocks it
home Lisa's the two Ball nine point lead
places goes to the screen Lottie inside
I think Wendy gotta yeah be two blocks
little delay set with them
on the wing goes through the legs
[Applause]
Wesley behind the Barlow screen
little midi comes off
[Applause]
great timing on it excellent wimby
staring him down and he forces the air
ball so there's the defensive impact
nice rim run and the punch Tibet dunks
Mr champagne in transition Mercy
he wants to hang his hat at the
defensive end with this team
or at least build an identity that way
when benyama missing got it back
and one
and a little Flex first of all again
playing on the perimeter nice face-up
quick decisive move puts it soft up on
the rim the get back random out top went
beyond the post up
glass there's the touch a fortuitous
bounce he's got 22. he had pushed a
position immediately and it's late now
he's got to Pivot to the other side but
the touch was at work the footwork is so
good
and the patience right yeah you're under
a little bit of pressure but he's like
got the switch on the screen has an eye
on him
flashes into the mid post
nice looking turnaround
wonderful execution
24 in the game to go with 10 rebounds
the bow with the sweep through block
[Applause]
a little pitch back from
Harlow wimpy for three quarter